[Musique]
tl-s margherita et ont piqué nous
cherchons à bon chat ça veut dire bien
sûr je sais très bien ce que ça veut
dire
il a mis l'accent romain jamais reconnu
la fille à faible buy out ou je veux pas
vivre dans une caravane tout mais un
jour tu regretteras notre vie de bohème
bras panon
si sa tante fait un concert classique
avec un orchestre de jeunes au début des
vacances carrément sais où tu en italie
à venise l'argent moi je ne trouve pas
sous le sabot d'un cheval français mais
j'aimerais trop y aller j'aime bien
meilleure idée
on va y aller tous ensemble à venise
c'est bien avec notre caravane
ça ne fait pas plaisir tous les chemins
mènent à rome et venise n'est pas bien
loin de rang
bienvenue chez les dingues juste en face
de venise et un camping pas cher du tout
on n'est pas bien ici incluent zina côté
original pu mais le fait pas de bruit
je te positive à l'amour il n'y a qu'une
règle de l'audace encore de l'audace
toujours de l'audace monfils
elle tente de nous on te convient pas
comme parents oui j'ai honte et je ne
conçois pas une famille normale mais ça
n'existe pas les gens normaux et mais
j'ai une grande nouvelle à t'annoncer
j'ai inventé paysage
tu sais comment j'ai baptisé huîtres
huîtres c'est lâche pas une mitre elle
papillon pavillon salage